[موسيقى]
جاء
حماري ذهب
حماري بالفرحه ينهق في الدار
ويشاركني كل
همومي ويرافقني في اسفاري جاء حماري جاء
حماري ذهب حماري ذهب حماري بالفرحه ينهق
في الدار ويشاركني ويشاركني كل همومي
عمومي ويرافقني في اسفري كان جحى يمشي
ويغني واندهش صغار وكبار سالته زوجته قالت
منذ متى ولدينا حمار يا امراتي اليوم
ساجلب اعتبريه هنا موجود قل يا جحا ان شاء
الله لما هكذا عقلك
محدود المال بجيبي والسوق بالقرب فلماذا
الضيق وعلى م القل يراودني ساجلب لا شيء
يعيق ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله قل يا جحا ان شاء الله
ان شاء
مر الوقت وعاد جحا يلطم يصرخ وغوث هرعت
زوجته تساله لم انت حزين يا جحا سرق اللص
المال وهرب ما بجيبي موجود لم اسمع نصحك
يا امراتي فانا من عقله محدود لم اذكر ان
شاء
الله ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله ان شاء الله جحى ان شاء
الله جح ان شاء
الله
ه